[Music]
so I got another one for you oh and that
is there is a highest possible
acceleration
for an automobile
I don't know if you know I uh I did I'd
say but you didn't know that okay yeah
but but it's a it's a Tesla in free fall
isn't Tesla in free fall anyway
is that is is that not a is that not a
euphemism chart
well that's that's kind of what I'm
getting at I thought you were so what
you're saying to me Neil is it's not if
you use an internal combustion engine
it's not about horsepower correct
correct or if you're using an electric
motor it's got nothing to do with those
correct okay so Watch What Happens so
let me let me lead you up to that all
right so there's the car sitting there
at the starting line
and what do you have to do
to have the car accelerate well you want
to have the wheel made of rubber
typically in contact with
cement or asphalt or yeah whatever okay
yeah and you want that wheel to propel
the car
right okay okay
and now you say to yourself I want to
accelerate even faster
so you put you press the pedal down even
harder right at a zero start okay we're
talking about 0 to 60 here let's say I'm
with you so now you say I want to go
even faster
there's a point where
as you press down the pedal
the torque on the wheels
right will be so high
that you'll skid out
right it will no longer be attached to
the road burning rubber baby okay so you
you've lost you've lost control of your
vehicle yeah no well well you've lost
you've lost the friction that moves you
forward oh okay because it's friction
between the tire and the road
that moves you forward okay so one way
to improve the traction
is to increase the force
over those Wheels
okay
I don't know if you've ever seen these
uh entrepreneurial folks who have pickup
trucks uh in the old days they were all
rear-wheel drive but the engine is in
the front
so what so the weight over the front
tires is way more than on the back tires
and they'd want to equip them with a
snow plow and then you know they go by
in the snowstorm and say you want me to
to you know plow your parking lot and
they pick up money on the spot okay so
they they will not have traction unless
they do what you know what they do
well um I normally they just have chains
on the car oh that helps that's okay
yeah together they're gonna have to wait
the back they're gonna have to wait the
back and there's an easy source of
weight to do that with and that's the
snow so they will shovel snow into the
back of the truck increase the downward
force on the drive Wheels which it for
the net model that I'm describing were
the rear wheels America went through
rear-wheel drive for most of you know
the 20th century of our cars and so that
increased the pressure there's so that
the wheels would not skid out okay okay
so now but wait
to increase the weight
the energy to accelerate has to move
more mass
right working against your ability
to accelerate
so you need more power to propel the car
because you have more mass or actually
more weight pushing down on the car
yes but in order to get the traction you
increase the weight but what I'm saying
is by increasing the weight
you have to then have a more powerful
engine in order to make this happen and
they scale exactly together
oh
that's my point see now you can get down
with Force Through air through airflow
I'm going to get there we'll get there
tomorrow okay get there in a moment okay
but I can tell you this you're not
having much of any downward air pressure
starting from zero no you're not gonna
get it right but you have to go much
higher speeds for that to really matter
here but there are at at race car speeds
they do matter right okay but even from
zero it doesn't matter zero is air is
not helping no okay right so so to
Gary's point when you have air pressing
down by using an airfoil of some kind
the spoiler right which if you look at
its cross section it's an upside down
airplane wing right you can have it you
can have air intakes inside of the
vehicles you see that there are other
there's other aerodynamic elements that
you can add that's right and this is how
does the how how does the car look in a
skirt okay right yeah okay but then you
have you have a you have uh vents that
direct air underneath the body correct
so we have a fast removing air going
under the car that creates a net
positive pressure down of just air and
the spoiler in the back depending on its
angle will also increase the pressure so
that way you increase the weight of the
car without increasing its mass all
right yeah okay and that improves your
traction
okay
but what I'm saying is
that when you run the numbers on this
what you get is that the fastest you can
accelerate
forward
is 1g
wow
that's okay all right you cannot
accelerate
with just normal friction between a a
tire and a road
faster than the acceleration of gravity
downward towards Earth
and when you run that calculation you
say well if you just free fall how long
does it take to get to 60 miles an hour
takes about three seconds
free fall
for a stone to reach 60 miles an hour
so horizontally this is playing out with
the weight of the car and your ability
to have the thing move forward without
spinning the wheels
right so there are two ways to improve
on this
right one of them is
lace the entire
with sticky gum okay okay right or or
more practically you heat the tire
heat the tire which
they do yeah then the tire gets gummy
so it is to the road but they use
different compounds nil don't they they
use I mean think about the hot rod drag
racing yeah they've got these tiny
little bicycle wheels up front like like
T-Rex arms yeah
they've got these gigantic pieces of
rubber monster truck slicks in the back
yeah correct so and that's that and I
mean that gummy compound that they use
and so they probably you know you can
spin it to heat heat it up to that and
it's gummy so it's sticking to the road
when you stick to the road
then you're not relying purely on
friction yeah to move forward in in
physics terms the coefficient of
friction
is greater than one
okay right and it you can only achieve
that oh by the way the code efficient
freaking Rubber and and Roads is very
high it's like 0.9 you know point point
eight point nine point nine five so
Rubber and roads are a match made in
heaven okay uh and now you keep getting
that up to one
then you'll accelerate forward at the
downward acceleration of Earth's gravity
you cannot do higher than unless it
grips the road in some kind of gummy way
sticky way or you know how to do it
perfectly you have
um gears
right okay then it's not friction at all
your teeth and your gears are pressing
against something else that's embedded
in the road guy you can accelerate to
any any rate you want yeah at that point
so it's all a matter of whether you're
only depending on friction or not
wow so you're not gonna have a car
accelerating at two seconds from zero to
sixty uh unless either it has something
digging into the road pockets of holes
in the road or there's a jet engine
so I mean electric cars
near the electric cars out there must be
close to about
two and a half three seconds naught to
sixty bikes certainly can so what
typically what's going on there is
that's on a particular track where
they're kind of tires they use are is
actually digging into the road okay
that's that's that's what's happening
there so but you'll see there's a
convergence down around three seconds
from zero to 60. and this this is the
reason you're you're limited by uh by
Earth basically and the acceleration of
gravity on Earth if you're only relying
on friction but like I said put a jet
engine there or rocket engine and then
then you're not relying on friction this
is the big issue with the land speed
record
are you allowed to have a rocket engine
where there's thrust coming out the back
if that's the case that's just a rocket
going horizontally right what are you
proving with that they're not going to
be popular in traffic are they nearby I
actually did I tell you I rode um
uh Jay Leno's a jet car oh I'm on one of
his episodes of well what do you call
his episode um garage yeah once on CNBC
I think it moved networks uh but yeah so
look at the one where is his it's his J
he has a a commercial jet engine
in the back of his car that's powering
the drivetrain
there was there was once a British guy
took the engine out of a World War II
Spitfire
claim right which would have been a 24
liter Rolls-Royce Merlin engine
and built a car around it and then would
drag it down the autobot and just duke
it out with Ferraris and forces
absolutely yeah he'll win because he's
not using normal friction exactly right
right if you leave the Ferrari in your
dust or in your in your plume it looked
like one of those old-fashioned 1910
Bentleys you know I've got a big open
Wheels
around on it yeah and so Jay Leno's car
was streetworthy and he even had like a
stereo in it I'm thinking really really
yeah I got a jet engine right behind me
here it's a two-seater the jet engine is
like behind my head oh I'm wearing a
helmet and he wants to hear Blue Danube
that's not happening yeah turn that up
that's my jam yeah
what was the heat like in strapped in to
a rocket that must have been ridiculous
well no so it has a cooling system so
and it's behind you so so now he's
working fine we were at Edwards Air
Force Base so they closed one of the
tracks for us and at something like 150
miles an hour one of the windows blew
out and they caught that on slow motion
and and but the car could have gone
faster and I said Jay obviously I'm in
the passenger seat I said Jay why don't
you take it up higher and Chuck you have
to imitate him now okay yeah
he said I didn't want to be known as the
guy who killed the astrophysicist
oh yeah yeah yeah you know people like
you
thank you
okay
yeah man so wow yeah so so you're
actually limited by the acceleration of
gravity that's it and how fast is it
when you shoot a car in the space
you want to shoot a Tesla Roadster yeah
exactly
yeah I mean the sky's the limit well the
relativity is the limit but uh there's
nothing to stop any rate of acceleration
in space
if you have engines and if you have
rocket engines you're just how fast
you're how good your engine works that's
all right nothing else is otherwise
limiting you but look up the look up the
acceleration speeds and if you find
something significantly faster than
three seconds at zero to 60 look
carefully at what the conditions were of
the track the road what kind of rubber
they used and uh and and whether or not
it was on Rails oh yeah yeah that's
right that's right rails that's a whole
other thing yeah oh that's another
conversation we're going to have like I
said in a previous uh in the previous
segment if you're on a rail then part of
your train is actually moving backwards
while you're moving forwards so wow I'm
still trying to wrap my head around
okay I can't wait to save that save that
one Chuck Gary we're out of time this
has been yet another explainer
and this has been a sports edition
version of that
love doing these I hope you guys love
them too oh yeah great time for it all
right Neil deGrasse Tyson here as always
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]